et à l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière à
paris le personnel médical se serre les
coudes plus que jamais pour victoria le
père chef de clinique assistant d'un des
saisies en réanimation la cohésion est
le maître mot
en ces temps de crise alors pour
l'instant ça va on est assez nombreux
personnes de l'équipe est malade pour
l'instant on est vraiment on a une
cohésion d'équipé extraordinaire et moi
personnellement je pense que j'ai
vraiment la chance d'avoir une équipe
comme ça on sert vraiment les coudes et
on discute beaucoup étaient qu'il ya un
problème dès qu'il ya une émotion un peu
difficile on en parle on garde rien pour
nous et il ya eu aussi une psychologue
dans le service auquel on peut faire
appel si jamais ça va vraiment pas il ya
des situations vraiment compliqué des
malades c'est une situation
extraordinaire actuellement c'est
difficile mais avec l'équipe avec le
soutien qu'on a entre nous ça va